warmer climes will have to wait
no government wants to dash dreams but
the summer holiday is for now
on ice it's another bitter blow for an
industry embattled
police travel agency hasn't taken any
money since march he's used up his
savings keeping it afloat
and he's having to move from his home he
says the impact of stricter rules and
sanctions
was immediate over the last two days
i have amended uh a lot of holidays
now that word you to travel in april and
may
to now travel in 2022. angry
disappointed and and just generally feel
feel let down but by the government
there's no specific
travel industry support whatsoever
the industry had hope these scenes were
behind it travelers did too
holiday company tui alone has booked 2.8
million summer holidays
but the prime minister made it clear
many may not happen
i'm afraid it is just uh too early for
people to
uh be certain about uh what we'll be
able to do
this summer and we hope to be able to
say more in the week of the 22nd
but that uncertainty is devastating for
people like jennifer and dave
their wedding in crete has already been
rearranged their disappointment eclipsed
only by stress
we've been left completely in limbo with
the whole situation we can't plan
anything you know we've got
all of our there are so many things
elements that come together for a
wedding and we can't plan anything
for it not to go ahead you know it's
supposed to be
the happiest time of your life and not
the most stressful
time and you need look no further than
crawley to see how deep the damage runs
it was estimated last year that over
half of the jobs here could be lost so
reliant is crawling
on neighbouring gatwick airport in a
letter seen by sky news the airline
industry body
has warned of a second lost summer if
that happens it won't just be disastrous
for those who work in airports
but those who drive taxis wait tables
and run hotels
for some it's already too late jill
worked out of gatwick as cabin crew for
ba
she took redundancy last year an early
reflection perhaps
of what's to come there's not another
job like it
i just i'd never be able to replace it
so it was pretty
devastating i actually had a little
meltdown last night when i
finally realized that even when things
come back to normal i'm not going to
have the same
lifestyle it just you know
it was a fulfilling job vaccine
passports may offer a route to places
like this
but for now a whole industry's resigned
to weight and relying on hope
helen and smith sky news and crawley